hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
Thursday the 29th of January today and
you're watching games what news the most
reliable source for news videos from
games fun Clinton there was a shorter
fans last year given their slew of great
games but they rub youtubers the wrong
way by claiming the profits of lets
players who played their games
previously when people post it up videos
playing Nintendo games nintendo claimed
all advertising proceeds from the videos
for themselves now that relationship has
either been mended or further
exacerbated with the Nintendo creators
program here uses register single videos
or entire channels they get reviewed and
approved by Nintendo then the company
will pay the creator sixty percent of
the total advertising revenue for a
single video or seventy percent per
channel however Nintendo has said these
rates may be changed arbitrarily and all
videos which apply must include
disclosure of program if you comply with
all these things you can expect to be
paid for the content you created two
months after the monthly views are
counted next up battlefield hardlines
open beta is coming so satisfied every
328 if you want to get into it the open
beta is global and will be coming to all
platforms unless you're in Japan where
the beta won't be on xbox platforms
there will be three modes you can sample
a team deathmatch mode which supports up
to 64 players called conquest Hotwire
which is a cops and robbers mode where
criminals attempt to take marks cars
while police try to keep them at bay and
heist which is basically paid a mixing
robbing a bank vault with getaways the
three maps available will be Dust Bowl
downtown and bank job and all modes will
provide the option to incorporate a
fourth pack and load where one player
attempts to hack the battlefield zones
to help out their team
and finally Bill Gates held his said
reddit AMA today where among other
things he talked about the hollow lens
and its application gates said the
hollow lens is pretty amazing Microsoft
has put a lot into the chips and the
software it is the start of virtual
reality making the device so you don't
get dizzy or nauseous is really hard the
speed of the alignment has to be super
super fast it will take years of
software applications being built to
realize the full illness of this gates
also talked at length about the next few
decades which he thinks will bring all
sorts of robots into service and
personal assistant positions and it's
totally well worth a read let me know
down in the comments what you'd want to
do with the hollow lens in the future if
the possibilities were unlimited you can
hedge against that wall we've got news
on February's PS plus titles and a
remake of Fahrenheit indigo prophecy
that is it for me today be sure to join
me same time tomorrow for five of this
week's very best stories I will catch
you been